thanks Ben and thanks for the invitation
to speak I just started my lab last July
so most of the my talk will be about
work that I did as a postdoc in Matthew
Meyerson slab at dana-farber in the
broad along with a work with a
collaborator Catherine woo so here's a
figure from one of the descriptions of
the pan-cancer analysis projects and the
goal of the project was to look at
various ohmic types such as mutation
copy number gene expression as a way to
look at all the ways that cancer genomes
are altered look across multiple tumor
types and try to identify the different
pathways that are altered and so
something that's missing from this
figure is the contributions from
alternative splicing and so the main
interests of my group is to look at ways
thats y singh is altered in cancer
transcriptomes and to understand how
that's actually contributing to
tumorigenesis briefly what is splicing
an alternate splicing so essentially
every gene in the human genome is
alternatively spliced so genes start out
for the pre-mrna and you can either
decide to include or skip a portion of
that pre-mrna typically we describe them
as say x on so you can have either X on
inclusion or excellent skipping and
these different decisions can actually
have a functional effect on the on the
gene so this is just one example of the
fast gene that can have inclusion or
skipping of exon six and this has very
different functions to the protein ones
a membrane-bound receptor one is soluble
and they have very antagonistic
functions
and so one indication that splicing was
really important in cancer was that
recent whole exome sequencing studies
had found that many recurrent mutations
occurred in splicing factors so these
are these typically were friend proteins
that were part of the course spliceosome
so here I'm showing two examples of
those splicing factors that have been
found to be mutated which I'll describe
in the talk today so one is you to a f1
and this is part of the you to AF
complex that's involved in three prime
splice site recognition and another
factor is called sf3 b1 which associates
with the branch point sequence within an
intron and is also thought to direct
splicing so what's very striking about
many of these splicing factor mutations
is that they occur across many tumor
types both in solid tumors and blood
malignancies the big question in the
field is to understand how these
mutations are contributing to
tumorigenesis so why are these mutations
being selected for and one kind of
common hypothesis is that these
mutations and sir splicing factors are
affecting the transcriptome and so if we
were able to then look at the set of
altered exon splicing events potentially
you may expect retain introns or our
unspliced of introns you may also
observe a gene expression changes due to
these mutations and if we were able to
then identify the collection of all
these transcriptome alterations we could
then potentially look at what are the
affected genes or pathways so when I
started my postdoc I looked into the
Cancer Genome Atlas which was a great
data source because for each tumor
sample as a part of the TCGA we had both
whole exome sequencing and matched mRNA
sequencing from the same tumor and so
we're able to then look for splicing
alterations in the same tumors that had
these meet
shins so the first gene that we looked
at was you to a f1 so what I'm showing
our just hotspot mutations in you 12 1
there there were additional mutations
found across other portions of the
protein but this s 34 position is the
the most frequently mutated position in
you to a f1 and what we also saw by
looking across all the TCGA tumors was
that this new this you to f1 gene was
most frequently mutated in AML and lung
adenocarcinoma and so those were the two
tumor types that we followed up on so
I'm simplifying a lot but essentially
what we did was to to look for splicing
changes due to this mutation we took the
collection of patients that showed no
mutations in any splicing factor and
compared them with the set of patients
that had mutations in this splicing
factor took the RNA seek data from those
patients and looked for differential
splicing so the approach that we used to
look for differential splicing I was to
use junk base so this was a program i
originally developed in my graduate work
that i have since been updating for
improvement with cancer genome studies
so the main benefit of junk base is that
it's able to detect splicing events
directly from the RNA seek data without
the without the need for an annotation
and actually this is really important
when thinking about looking for splicing
changes due to a splicing factor
mutation we may we may expect that many
splicing changes have never been seen
before since these are patients and core
factors so with junk base you're able to
detect alternative splicing it also
classifies the splicing in these
different types which I'll show is is
also very informative to study these
factors and junk base can also quantify
alternative splicing I'll go through one
example of that and so this is a
representation of an alternative three
prime splice site event
we're in the white box is representing
an alternative Exxon or a portion of an
excellent and there's two different
isoforms choices there's one that
includes the white Exxon and there's one
that skips the white X on and the what's
represented in red are RNA seek reads
that would support inclusion of that
isoform and in blue i'm showing
representation of reads that would
support skipping so junk base will
identify these reeds and assign the
reeds to either the inclusion or
exclusion isoform from those reads it
calculates an abundance of of the
isoform and then of the two different
isoforms and then from that it can
calculate a percent spliced in which is
essentially the proportion of the
inclusion isoform that's expressed
relative to the total abundance so for
this one psi value we can we can or we
can I quantify this psi value for every
patient sample and for every splicing
event and then we can perform
differential splicing analysis on the on
this value so here I'm showing a real
plot of psi values for one particular
splicing event and what we what we're
doing is we're comparing the PSI values
between wild-type and mutated samples
and so we can do this for every event
and then after multiple testing
correction we can get a set of strongly
associated splicing changes that are
correlating with this mutation so for
long adenocarcinoma and AML we we looked
into the splicing changes that were
associated with this with this mutation
and what I'm showing is what a
classification of those splicing events
that we saw and so we saw primarily
cassette excellent type events being
affected as well as alternative three
prime splice site events that were
affected and this was actually promising
because this was what we expected given
the known function of
12-1 as part of you to AF complex that's
involved in three prime splice site
recognition and I apologize it's really
small but we we saw a total of 131
splicing changes in lung adenocarcinoma
and 369 strongly associated splicing
changes in AML so these mutations seem
to be affecting hundreds and hundreds of
splicing changes and so one of the
challenges and something I'm planning to
continue in my own lab is to try to
understand what the functional
consequences of these slicing changes
are so here i'm just showing three genes
that were shown to be affected given
some of their known roles in cancer as
well as RNA processing so one we were
particularly interested in was beta
catenin as that's a gene that's
frequently mutated in cancers primarily
through missense mutation but this is
just to illustrate some of the
challenges of understanding the
consequence of these mutations so beta
catenin the event we saw was altered in
both AML and lung adenocarcinoma and we
could show that this was actually caused
caused by the mutation by these
validation experiments where we
expressed a wild-type and ute ated forms
of the protein and could show that
indeed the mute the mutation does cause
a splicing alteration of beta-catenin so
this event occurred in the three prime
utr of beta-catenin we try to follow up
a little bit on if it's affecting beta
carotene expression or downstream
pathways and or the the pathway that
medication is involved in and we didn't
see anything obvious from from that
analysis so it's still unclear even
though we're seeing this very conserved
splicing change it's unclear how that's
actually affecting the pathway so what I
just described was our studies on the
effects of e2f1 mutation and so another
way that we could perhaps understand the
functions of these mutations is to look
at other splicing factors and maybe
compare what are those transcriptome
effects so
another one that we looked at is SF Ruby
one so again it's a factor that's
associated with the branch point and is
also involved in regular regulation of
splicing so so3 be one is actually one
of the most prevalent mutations in
chronic lymphocytic leukemia and so this
work is in collaboration with catherine
was lab so this is a review from the wu
lab showing the locations of the most
frequent SF 31 mutations in CLL and so
these do occur and this heat repeat
domain and the most common the most
frequently mutated position is this case
700e so again we can use the same
approach so take the samples that have
no mutation the splicing factors and
compare those with the samples that have
the mutation and look for splicing
differences so again we see that sfe one
mutation causes altered three prime
splice site usage however unlike you to
AF one we don't see as many cassette
exon cases which here is showing a light
blue so so3 be one seems to strongly
affect three prime splice site changes
as well as differential intron usage so
some additional we've done some
additional functional studies of some of
these slicing changes to under
understand what's what's functionally
happening with these mutations one kind
of computational look is just to ask how
many of these mutations are inferring
than out of frame so in the presence of
the mutation we're seeing a splicing
switch and that would be that most in
the majority of cases predicted to be an
out of frame mutation so would thus be
predicted to be a loss of function for
those jeans another another thing to
point out is that many of these splicing
changes involved usage of a novel splice
site that was never annotated so again
it's really important
in these studies that were when we're
looking at splicing factor mutations to
look at potentially unannotated splicing
changes so one of the interesting in
frame deletion so just to go back so
most things were out of frame but we
were also interested in genes that might
be that might fall into this category
where they're in frame that may indicate
that the splicing change is potentially
gain of function or a change of function
in that gene so one of the genes we we
have followed up with is DV l2 or
dishevelled so the wint pathway is well
known to be altered in CLL and
dishevelled is this component of the
pathway and what I'm showing here is our
NAC coverage along this event so the
alternative three prime splice site is
here and down below is showing 1
transcript annotation and so what you
can see is that in the presence of the
mutation a more downstream 3 prime
splice site is being used so you can see
the drop in coverage in the mutated
sample and again not an annotated splice
site and so some functional follow-up
that my collaborator Kathy woo and Lily
wing have done is to show that this y
singh that actually does have a
functional effect on the protein so just
to summarize kind of what we're seeing
with these splicing fact mutations on
how I you know we're sort of framing it
is that these mutations like the known
transcription factor mutations are
having very plié tropic effects so
classically p53 one of the most
frequently mutated genes and cancer is
known to affect many many different
downstream pathways and have many
different effects on the cell and so we
can kind of think of it similar with
splicing factors these are global gene
regulators and what we're seeing based
on our transcriptome analyses is that we
many different pathways that are
directly being affected by these
differences and another interesting
point is that based on our studies and
other studies on these splicing factors
as well as others that I haven't shown
it does appear that these mutations have
different effects on the cell so there's
different sets of splicing and gene
expression changes sometimes you do see
common pathways that are affected but
uncommonly you don't see the same exact
gene affected by these mutations so it's
still it's still kind of a mystery as to
why these are being we're currently
altered but I think by looking at these
global changes in RNA seek data we are
getting more on gaining more information
as to what their effects are so one way
and that we're looking at somatic
mutations that disrupt RNA splicing
regulation is through these mutations in
splicing factors and another way that
we're looking at mutations in the cancer
genomes that affect splicing is through
mutations and splicing regulatory
elements or sis elements so these are
mutations either directly at the splice
sites or potentially within the X on or
within the flanking intron and all these
sequences the sequences are known to
typically act as binding sites for for
transacting factors and these sequences
can also be mutated and then affect a
splicing downstream
so one of the slicing changes that we've
been we've characterized previously is
an atty receptor tyrosine kinase called
met so this is just a diagram of many
receptor tyrosine kinases these are
genes that are frequently mutated in
cancer either through missense mutation
fusion amplification and so forth and so
we're looking into also those cases
where they're affected by splicing so it
had been previously known so back in two
thousand six and two thousand nine it
had been shown that met is is altered
through splice site mutations so here
I'm showing particular positions that
were shown to be mutated at the five
prime splice site and also these
deletions were identified around met
exon 14 and the consequence of these
mutations were skipping of exon 14 so in
a wild-type sample with no mutation exon
14 would then in the protein level
contain a binding site for sybil which
is a ubiquitin ligase and so normally
then met can be ubiquitinated and then
further degraded however if you skip
exon 14 which can come up which can come
about from any of these splice site
mutations then you would skip the exon
14 and remove that binding site and so
you get a more stabilized protein so
this was really an interesting event
because typically in cancer genome
studies when you look at splice site
mutations it's always assumed to be loss
of function but this is one case where
these splice site mutations are actually
causing a gain-of-function activation of
an oncogene and so as part of the TCGA
lung adenocarcinoma working group we
wanted to further characterize this
event and again we had whole exome and
RNA seek from the exact same tumor types
and from that analysis we actually
identified an unexpected nonsense
mutation that was associated with Exxon
14 skipping so I'm down here I'm showing
just a model of the exons 13 14 and 15
and then above here i'm showing coverage
of RNA seek reads in two different
patient samples the top row is a
wild-type sample the bottom row is this
one patient that had this Y 1003 stop or
nonsense mutation what's interesting is
this why 1003 mutation actually falls
directly in the Exxon and what I'm not
showing is that it's predicted to cause
a loss of splicing enhancers and this is
something that we're interested in
further testing and so really the
take-home message was if we didn't have
the matched exome and RNA seek data we
wouldn't have been able to identify this
association and most importantly this is
a nonsense mutation that's then being
shown to be associated with a
gain-of-function alteration this is
really important in the context of
treatment so what's very promising is
that patients that have these met
splicing alterations actually show
response to targeted met therapies and
so by identifying more of these or
understanding all these different ways
that met and other targetable genes are
altered we can potentially help to
improve our understanding of how we can
target patients for specific
and so just briefly I'll talk about some
other goals of identifying additional
sis acting mutations so we're kind of
systematically looking for assists
mutations in the exome and whole genome
sequencing data and then asking do you
see an Associated spicing change and one
interesting case we've observed is
actually in erbe to which is another one
of these receptor tyrosine kinases so
this is out of the 230 lung
adenocarcinomas that we originally
studied what I'm showing here is a graph
of of the expression of X on 16 and
there's this one page so if you notice
pretty much all patients have about a
hundred percent spliced in meaning most
of them are expressing that exon but
there's this one patient that shows a
dramatic skipping of that exxon and this
was the only sample that actually showed
a splice site mutation in ur b 2 and
just to show that this wouldn't have
been identified if we had simply used
the annotation as this is a in the
transcript annotation this exon is is
constitutive and so n of 1 is kind of
risky to make any conclusions on but
what was really promising is sort of
just doing some google searching we
found that this splicing event had
actually been functionally characterized
before and so we're further testing this
as well but essentially in in this
transformation assay expressing control
or wild type or unknown activating irby
to point mutation versus this exon 16
deletion what this group found was that
that exon 16 deletion can also transform
very similarly to a known activating or
b2 mutation and so so far no one this
isoform was reported breast cancer had
never been reported in lung cancer and
no somatic mutation had ever been linked
to that excellent
and again rb2 is a one targetable cancer
alteration and so we're interested in
following up on this and then finally we
are also involved in the pan-cancer
analysis whole pan-cancer analysis of
whole genomes group and mainly because
we're interested in looking for
mutations that are farther into the
introns which are typically missed by
whole exome sequencing studies so one
example is Right adjacent to the exon
there's these splice site motifs and in
typical exome sequencing we only call
mutations right near the exon but
there's additional information that
flanks that region and also it's known
that intronic regulatory elements exist
and so we're looking in these whole
genome sequencing data to look for
additional cases of splicing occasions
so we'll continue to mine cancer genome
and transcriptome data to look at the
various ways that splicing can be stated
and I'll end with just thinking my
collaborators particularly from Matthew
Meyerson slab and Kathy woo
patient's to the work that i presented
it's all answer any questions picture of
cancer this pricing communication are
not very frequent so today a cure in
combination with other mutations can
they drive cancer by themselves do you
have this bigger picture of the kind of
role fight itself yeah great question um
so they frequently do occur a co-occur
with known drivers so for example among
adenocarcinoma the Ute or mutations
frequently occur with k rossi GFR those
kind of canonical driver mutations when
people have tried to make mouse models
introducing the mutations themselves
they're subtle phenotypes but they don't
you don't see the very strong
proliferative effect that you would see
if with canonical driver mutations and
so people are looking at common
combinations of mutations together to
see what is potentially the additional
selective advantage that factors are
doing
say something about this by some
reference that changed you to the
mutation yeah yeah I didn't I kind of I
took that out so the UIF one it's
actually really interesting well I guess
I'll this is my bonus slide so for you
to f1 we do actually see different three
prime splice site sequence recognition
and so this is a the splice site motif
of canonical human splice sites when we
see skipping of three prime splice sites
the splice site that's avoided has a TA
G and then when you look at it the other
way when you when you're preferring a
more proximal splice site again you're
avoiding splicing at a at a TA G so
that's one feature of e2f1 as a3 b1
totally different so you don't see any 3
prime splice site recognition alteration
what you're seeing there's some debate
but essentially a differential branch
point usage that corresponds to a
different three prime splice site change
you try to model it in the way that you
can even the mutation you think 50 yeah
so for you to f 1 i've done that a
little bit and it does seem that there's
a strong enrichment that if you if
there's two splice sites that are nearby
and one is a teg and one is a CG there's
a majority of those are affected by the
mutation but we haven't we haven't gone
further to actually build like a
stronger model for that but we do see
that those when you have those two
choices that there's a strong bias for
those to be affected
it's splicing factors have to be
appropriate effects why don't we see
more splicing factors why only these two
so those were the only two I talked
about but they're actually many others
there's some lung cancers r BM 10
there's been studies on SRS f1 there so
there's also overexpression there's
mutations and srs of two there's so
there have been a lot that have been
identified there's also other set of
sort of epigenetic modifiers that
potentially could also affect splicing
and that has been shown as well so
perhaps we just there are maybe they're
free they're mutated more frequently but
we haven't maybe identified the causal
link good well then games